muy buenas noches a las gracias por este
espacio nosotros el día de ayer nos
reunimos con el embajador de eeuu en
guatemala para trasladarle nuestra
solicitud de parte del gobierno de
guatemala para el tps a nuestros
connacionales en eeuu
estamos en espera de una respuesta
sabemos que esto puede tardar entendemos
la coyuntura política que está viviendo
en este momento ha derivado de las
elecciones eeuu pero este es un asunto
es un momento de emergencia es una
crisis humanitaria que está sufriendo el
pueblo de guatemala donde se decretó
estado de calamidad en 10 departamentos
donde se tienen miles y centenares de
personas damnificadas estamos haciendo
todos los esfuerzos que están en nuestro
alcance incluyendo el apoyo y la
solidaridad de la cooperación
internacional para poder llegar a las
personas más afectadas en este momento
se ha entregado alimentos se han llevado
albergues pero realmente esta situación
nos lleva a una necesidad de pedir
es el gobierno de los eeuu ya que no
contamos con la capacidad como para
poder trasladar y llevar a sus
comunidades y todo ese proceso logístico
de transporte ha quedado muy impedido en
muchas zonas y comunidades de guatemala
y más allá de este apoyo que le
solicitan a eeuu canciller que tan grave
es la situación que dejó eta guatemala
necesita ayuda internacional
bueno nosotros hicimos un llamamiento
internacional y solicitamos el apoyo a
la cooperación extranjera ya que como
sabes nosotros pues como todos los
países del mundo hemos sufrido una
pandemia derivada del cob y 19 esta
pandemia nos ha llevado a cierres y
limitaciones de la dinámica comercial lo
cual ha reducido la recaudación
tributaria y por lo tanto ha afectado la
situación financiera del país hemos
destinado a través del liderazgo del
presidente alejandro giammatei y
considerables sumas del presupuesto para
poder fortalecer el sistema de salud y
en ese caso poder estar preparados para
la pandemia no contábamos con que esta
tormenta viniera a afectarnos aún más y
por lo tanto se ven superadas las
capacidades nacionales y esto nos lleva
a hacer un pronunciamiento de un
llamamiento internacional las
condiciones actualmente son delicadas
hay muchos muchos ciudadanos en
condiciones de vulnerabilidad y por eso
es que en este momento entendiendo que
está que un asunto de catástrofes y
desastres naturales es considerable
el gobierno de los eeuu para tener un
tps es que emprendimos esta iniciativa
de la cual nosotros esperamos poder
poder tener una respuesta de carácter
humanitaria rápida para poder atender
esta emergencia que nos permita que los
migrantes guatemaltecos los los
guatemaltecos que está actualmente en
eeuu que es una mayor porcentaje de
inmigrantes en el extranjero puedan
tener un es un estatus de protección
temporal que les permita trabajar de
manera regular temporalmente mientras
ayudan a sus comunidades ya sus familias
también con esas remesas que envían
canciller pedrolo usted nos identifica
esta situación política que está
atravesando de eeuu que espera del
presidente electo joe biden el gobierno
guatemalteco y ya lo felicito
bueno nosotros ya felicitamos al pueblo
de norteamérica por esas elecciones
felicitamos al candidato electo
obviamente sabemos que hay algunos
procesos que se están llevando a cabo en
los tribunales de justicia que esperamos
que se resuelvan lo más pronto posible y
nosotros esperamos que que la
administración que el gobierno de los
eeuu ya sea este o el próximo año puedan
darnos una solicitud o una autorización
aprobación positiva para nosotros es
sumamente importante que los
guatemaltecos que actualmente están en
eeuu que son trabajadores que son
productivos y que además alimenta mucho
la economía del país puedan seguir allá
y puedan seguir contribuyendo a sus
comunidades como lo han hecho ya que
casi un 13% del pib representan las
remesas para la economía guatemalteca